supongamos que soy un productor de vino
de vino aquí voy a pintar unos ejes para
contarte algunas ideas y hacer un
pequeño repaso de lo que hemos visto
hasta ahora entonces en este eje voy a
poner el precio de mis botellas de vino
le voy a poner aquí pesos por botella
pesos por botella y de este lado va a
ser cantidad que va a ser botellas por
semana
por semana entonces digamos que aquí son
100 200 300 400 pesos por botella de
vino 10 500 y aquí son 100 200 300 400
botellas y a la semana bueno lo primero
que quiero hacer es dibujar la curva de
demanda entonces supongamos que si el
precio es muy alto es de 500 no se
venden botellas y si el precio es de 0
se venden 400 botellas para hacer las
cosas sencillas vamos a suponer que esto
es un modelo lineal entonces estoy acá
es la curva de demanda demanda ahora una
cosa importante es que mi vino va a ser
un producto altamente diferenciado es
decir tiene ciertas características
especiales que hace que la competencia
sea imperfecta entonces aunque haya
otros tipos de vino en el mercado como
el mío tiene algunas cosas muy muy
especiales básicamente dentro de este
tipo de vino es el único en su clase y
por tanto más o menos está en un
monopolio entonces déjame ponerle que se
llama mi dyno entonces me di no tiene
así características super especiales que
lo hacen único en su clase y básicamente
lo podemos pensar como un monopolio
de esta forma como ya vimos también en
vídeos anteriores la curva del ingreso
marginal
voy a poner así
la curva del ingreso marginal tiene el
doble de pendiente que la curva de
demanda y luego la curva de costo
marginal no sabemos muy bien cómo se ve
pero más o menos es como una curva con
pendiente positiva y es algo de este
estilo que un poquito choca pero no
importa esta de acá es la de costo
marginal
finalmente déjame ponerle poner la curva
de costo promedio total ésta empieza
haciendo alta porque al principio los
gastos fijos no nos quitan mucho de
bueno nos hacen muy cara cada botella
luego empieza a bajar estás baja un poco
más pero llega un punto en el cual ya no
conviene tanto producir más botellas
porque no dan tanta utilidad y no
disminuyen tanto los costos fijos
entonces estoy acá es el costo promedio
total bueno entonces pues de aquí ya
podemos decir varias cosas acerca de la
producción y justo como estamos en un
entorno de monopolio como mi vino es un
producto diferenciado entonces puedo
decir que este de aquí es el punto en el
cual voy a dejar de producir vino porque
porque justo aquí el ingreso marginal
deja de ser más grande que el costo
marginal al principio tenemos utilidades
la utilidad económica utilidad económica
pero al llegar a este punto ya no el
costo marginal es más grande que el
ingreso marginal cada unidad adicional
cuesta más entonces digamos que a esta
altura produzco 150 botellas y el precio
es a ojo verdad
el precio no se lee sobre esta curva
sino sobre la curva de demanda porque en
la curva de demanda es cuando está
dispuesto a pagar el consumidor entonces
el precio está más o menos por aquí
bueno supongamos que este precio es de
330 si se ve más o menos como 330 ok
entonces estoy produciendo 150 botellas
a la semana y me están demandando 150
bueno porque son las que produzco a 330
pesos cada botella entonces cuánto
dinero estoy ganando bueno pues para
encontrar cuánto estoy ganando tiene
tengo que ver cuánto me cuesta cada
botella qué es esto de acá restarle el
costo promedio por botella o sea cuánto
cuesta cada botella esto de acá y
multiplicarlo por el número de botellas
eso geométricamente tiene una
interpretación déjame ponerlo así
tenemos esta altura tenemos esto aquí
este largo y entonces aquí no sé más o
menos se ven como 250 pesos de costo
promedio total pero ahorita no quiero
meterme mucho en las cuentas nada más
quiero dejar indicado que esto de aquí
sería mi utilidad económica
no voy a poner utilidad económica
económicas todo esto es un repaso de lo
que ya hemos visto ahora otra cosa que
también ya vimos en lo del excedente del
consumidor ya platicamos de eso en
vídeos pasados que básicamente la idea
de que aquí hay personas que están
dispuestos a pagar más por mi botella de
vino por ejemplo a esta persona de acá
este le estoy vendiendo en 330 pesos
algo que ella piensa que vale como 450
verdad y a todo este excedente que le
estamos dando por encima de las
expectativas del cliente que pueden
poner bueno ya que estamos dando o que
estamos cobrando de menos por lo que los
clientes están dispuestos a pagar le
llamamos el excedente del consumidor
excedente del consumidor consumidor ok
entonces hasta ahorita digamos que en el
mercado de vinos a nadie se le había
ocurrido vender pues vino a distintos
precios a distintos consumidores porque
dicen no cómo vender a distinto precio a
distintas personas pero digamos que yo
soy un productor de vino muy creativo
este muy ingenioso y digo ah ya sé se me
va a ocurrir venderle a un mayor precio
la botella de vino a estas personas de
acá
a estas personas y a las que están
dispuestas a pagar digamos 400 pesos les
voy a vender mis primeras 100 botellas
de vino y cómo le hago para lograr eso
pues yo voy a seguir produciendo
exactamente el mismo vino si no voy a
cambiar de tipo de vino ni nada porque
eso cambiaría esta curva de demanda todo
es considerando que todo lo demás está
fijos de peris paribus entonces voy a
vender exactamente el mismo vino solo
que a las primeras 100 personas se los
voy a vender a 400 pesos con una
estrategia de mercado de la siguiente
forma en mis primeras 100 botellas en
mis primeras 100 botellas voy a poner
una etiqueta que diga vino premium
premium
especial especial y que diga para los
conocedores del vino o algo así entonces
dice vino premium especial tiene todas
las etiquetas de los premios que he
ganado y además lo voy a vender en los
mejores restaurantes y en las mejores
boutiques de la ciudad y entonces lo voy
a poder vender en estos 400 pesos
entonces qué sucede ahora estas primeras
100 botellas les estoy ganando más
y observa no voy a dejar de producir 150
entonces mi costo promedio total sigue
siendo esto lo único que estoy haciendo
es que las primeras 100 botellas las voy
a vender con esta estrategia entonces el
costo promedio total ahora va a ser
igual bajo y por tanto voy a tener una
mayor utilidad económica por esas
primeras 100 botellas todo este
rectángulo ahora va a ser de utilidad
económica para mí y lo otro lo voy a
pintar con este color naranja las otras
50 botellas pues para que no se vea tan
feo le voy a poner vino clásico vino
clásico clásico y lo voy a vender en el
supermercado entonces lo voy a vender en
el supermercado pero nada más en 330
pesos y claro que va a haber demanda
para el derecho social había demanda de
incluso más verdad había demanda de 150
para cuando estaba en este precio bueno
ok entonces qué sucede después de hacer
esta estrategia lo que acaba sucediendo
es que yo tuve más utilidad económica
tuve este rectángulo adicional este de
acá déjame marcarlo con este color
entonces este rectángulo adicional ahora
es mío entonces con esta estrategia
básicamente agarré un poco del excedente
del consumidor y me lo apropie para mi
utilidad económica lo que hice fue
discriminar entre los distintos clientes
discriminar precios entre los que
estaban dispuestos a pagar mucho y poco
y justamente a eso se le conoce como
discriminación discriminación
discriminación de precios de precios
precios estoy acá es discriminación de
precios de primer grado hay otro tipo de
discriminación es de precio pero la idea
básicamente es eso nos fijamos en
personas que están dispuestas a pagar
más por el producto y a estas personas
les vendemos pues las botellas de vino
en este caso a un mayor precio con eso
lo que logramos es tomar un poco del
excedente del consumidor
formarlo en utilidad económica para
nosotros